we might know the story of how young
jason voorhees rose from the deep to
slaughter generations of hormonal teens
but we may not know much about the actor
who played the hockey loving homicidal
maniac there's a lot more to being a
cinematic monster than waving a prop
machete at a babysitter it's time we
turn off the gore for a little bit and
look at the horror movie characters
behind the mask pinhead although writer
Clive Barker didn't name the lead bad
guy pinhead and his novel - hell bound
heart the characters distinctive
appearance earned him the nickname that
stuck throughout the Hellraiser series
which first launched in 1987 English
actor Doug Bradley has become synonymous
with the soul harvesting pinhead he's
become part of a special group of horror
actors who have played their haunting
characters at least six times in a row a
list that includes jigsaw played by
Tobin Bell the Leprechaun played by
Warwick Davis Brad Dourif is Chucky and
well this next guy Freddy Krueger as
much as we liked Jackie Earle Haley in
that Nightmare on Elm Street remake only
one actors name will always truly be
associated with our horror movie
nightmares Robert Englund we've seen
England where the blood for nearly two
decades playing Freddy Krueger in eight
films and even in the characters own
anthology horror series Freddy's
nightmares sure Freddy got a lot funnier
and sillier as the years went by but Wes
Craven's new nightmare was a proper
return to form for the supernatural
slasher hopefully England puts on the
Fedora sweater and glove one last time
for a final trip down Elm Street
Leatherface tobe Hooper's cooky 1974
horror flick the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
spawned all kinds of weird sequels but
there's no comparison to the original
heavily inspired by the horrific true
story of Ed Gein Leatherface were a
headpiece made of human skin while
plenty of people have picked up the
chainsaw since
Gunnar Hanson was the original actor to
take on the role Hanson set the standard
for the other leather faces who followed
laying the groundwork for how to
properly play the chainsaw wielding
maniac
- the b-movie mosquito will also
recognize Hanson as one of its main
characters who actually uses a chainsaw
to fight off enormous blood sucking bugs
that's a lot of chainsaws but has
anybody ever seen the guy cut down a
tree the alien Ridley Scott's alien
revolutionized both the science fiction
and horror movie genres in 1979 in the
beginning no one knew who was gonna be
cast as the film's terrifying monster
until Scott was introduced to bôla' he
bowed a hoe a design student from
Nigeria but a host thin frame and 7-foot
to height would help convince viewers
that the film's monster couldn't just be
another guy in a suit while they only
played the alien in the first film of
the franchise he still left a heavy
impression but de hos alien is just a
bodysuit but he ended up doing an
amazing job to help sell the illusion
and the creature would go on to be one
of Hollywood's most unforgettable
monsters right up there with
Frankenstein Dracula and Randy Quaid the
predator originally jean-claude van
damme was cast to play the predator in
the 1987 flick of the same name
unfortunately the bulked out appearance
of star Arnold Schwarzenegger and the
rest of the cast made Van Damme seem way
too small for the role how amazing would
it have been if the predator had come
flew skills instead Kevin Peter Hall who
also starred as the towering title
character and Harry and the Hendersons
snagged the role when you've got guys
like Jesse the body Ventura and Carl
Weathers walking around a jungle you're
gonna want to make your movie monster a
behemoth and not just the muscles from
Brussels Van Damme you're great but
we'll call you when we need a predator
that can do the splits because of my big
legs and karate I can do the splits
no prob
we know dude any wise a fear clowns is
pretty common and for a generation of
horror film fans a lot of that can be
attributed to the 1990 made for TV
miniseries it's based on Stephen King's
best-selling horror novel penny wise
dancing clown played by Tim Curry was
just one of a few horrific forms taken
by the nefarious spirit that haunted
that small town in Maine by this point
this career curry was known for playing
the Lord of darkness and legend and dr.
Franken further in the Rocky Horror
Picture Show Curry's captivating
terrifying performance was the
miniseries saving grace
despite the gory ER parts being hindered
by TV restrictions whatever they do with
the upcoming remake bill skarsgård has
some rather large shoes to fill and not
just because he's a clown Jason Voorhees
10 actors have played the character of
Jason Voorhees but we're going to have
to choose Kane Hodder as the definitive
hockey mask murderer totally
no not Hodor hotter while he didn't even
sign on to the series until Friday the
13th part 7 the new blood ha tears roll
helped bring Jason into a new age of
slasher flicks and made him the hulking
unstoppable Menace that we all love
today he's also had the most experience
playing Jason wearing the mask in four
films hotter remains a horror movie
heavyweight champion he also kind of
played leather face once as a stunt man
and the Texas Chainsaw Massacre 3
Michael Myers Jack carpenters low-budget
1978 slasher flick Halloween added a
heavy psychological aspect to the killer
that we hadn't seen since Norman Bates
decades prior and turn the film's
fictional idyllic suburb into an
unspeakably creepy place after the
sunset on October 31st Nick Castle who
is primarily a director and screenwriter
may have only done the mask in the first
movie but his awesome performances
Michael Myers would be imitated for
years Castle even co-wrote carpenters
dystopian action flick Escape from New
York
helped write the story for Steven
Spielberg's hook and has directed a long
list of movies that includes the
starfighter and now for a bonus fact now
we just talked about who was first under
that Michael Myers mask but what about
the face behind the mask itself none
other than William Shatner that's right
a mold of Captain Kirk's face terrorized
Jamie Lee Curtis and then Shatner
himself decided to terrorize the houses
in the neighborhood when he went
trick-or-treating with his kids
then I bought one and took the three of
you trick-or-treating I put on my own
masks thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to